do you ever get people that think you're
a fake Guru I'm super transparent about
my intention I'm here to absolutely make
money but I just don't need most
people's money we have 16 companies in
the portfolio right now my Equity stake
is probably worth I don't know 5 10 ish
million how many thousand dollar courses
do I have to sell to do that a lot like
there's a cap to how much money you can
make if that's the game so for me to get
to a billion I'm not going to get there
selling courses I have to own something
that's worth a billion the reason I had
the book it's 99 Cents and like so many
people from like Bangladesh and like
Pakistan like they can buy the book and
they're like I get all these thank you
messages which is cool part of the
reason I'm doing this way is because
like I kind of want to prove a point
which is that like you don't have to
play the game the same way and so
everyone gets a little bit of Goodwill
and they try monitor but if you can just
deposit and deposit and deposit and then
you just keep proving it wrong then that
doubter actually ends up becoming your
biggest fan